Mark Norman's here Mark Norman is
entering what's going on pal hey buddy
how know yeah same old yeah I do good to
be here first timer yeah is this your
first time on our show yeah oh good man
it's good to see us yeah nice to have
you we were talking about you after we
saw uh Amy at Madison Square Garden and
how well you did oh you were great man
you were really funny have you gotten
comfortable in in
Aras yeah weird uh that was a hot show I
was the second time doing it so the
first time I was [__] a brick and
this time I was like ah [__] it let's
have fun yeah and it was so much easier
also uh I didn't know Madonna and
Chappelle were watching which was good
yeah yeah yeah that would have [__]
you up right oh my God I I had my
lanyard on you guys saw the whole time
find like a true ass yes a complete dork
yeah uh I believe this will get me
backstage won't it will will this allow
me to be in my dressing room you talk to
Madonna uh yeah she laughed at one of my
jokes and uh it was about it was a Nazi
joke and I got off stage I said hey
thanks for thanks for watching my set
she goes great Nazi joke and I said
great and she walked away who who you
been more nervous about her or Chappelle
watching you oh Chappelle he's a comic
I'm a fan and yada yada but that's kind
of where you want Madonna to walk away
right the last thing you need is an
awkward interaction like she's
complimented you right she liked the
comedy now leave before the anybody has
any chance to ruin this did you see her
ass uh I did not amazing ass for 88 she
looks great it's a real shelf it's up
there yeah I'd love to see it wait that
night you mean yeah what was she wearing
I I was there but I didn't remember the
she had like a look at that that's not a
bad Caboose it does look really good
adri just Google imaged it yeah I'd give
that a little nuzzle would you kiss it
oh yeah i' give that a little brown
nosing yeah why not yeah she's a
material girl here's the worst part I
get off stage and I see Chappelle and he
goes great set I oh my God thank you
goes nice lanyard I was like ah [__]
damn it one of my heroes that's that's
why you want him to walk away
immediately after this nice set but then
I see him a week later and he and uh and
will svin I don't know if you know will
svin but he's like I'm opening for
Chappelle come watch I like I've never
seen Chappelle do a real set I'll go
watch I show up he goes lanyard and he
throws me
on for yeah that's great because of the
lanyard you know I have a the that stuff
works out I feel like uh uh I was
Synergy that's not synergy that's not
what that word means doesn't work at all
uh I think that the only reason that
Chris Rock gave me as much screen time
in his movie as he did cuz I had like I
had a good 25 seconds of screen time in
in in top five top yeah which is a lot
and he didn't have to I could have
easily been cut out cuz I didn't say
anything I didn't add anything and I
think it's just because I want can you
isolate that clip by the
way I'm saying that I think it's because
he got a kick out of the fact that I
look like Malcolm Gladwell ah walked in
yes you I never thought about that I
never either but he walked in he called
me Malcolm Gladwell when he walked in
and he was laughing about it and blah
blah blah and then we Shot the movie and
then he did it again next time he was in
and I was like okay and then the movie
came out and I was like Jesus Christ he
left me in and then I saw him on the
street like a year after the movie came
out and he went hey not Malcolm Gladwell
and I was like yeah that was what it was
yeah the whole thing the
synergize thing
isation yes and if it was it wouldn't
fit this context yes it would at all
it's not so where did you work where was
uh Dave doing the uh we did The Cutting
Room oh right which is a great little
room yeah and it was like one of these
like you got to be in the know to get
seats so the crowd was like hot and
ready to be there and then I did well on
that so he had me at the grar SE theater
open wow which that guy is a nut he
makes all of his crowd stand up there's
no they take out all the seats and he
had a guy on then me then Tom seura then
he did a set and then he did a sit down
with Chris Rock at the end the whole
show is like 8 hours Jesus Christ I know
and the crowd loved it yeah but they
stand the whole time the whole time why
does he do that I don't I think he likes
them he wants to be up and at him yeah
well no there's more no there's more you
can make more money that way there's
more people oh is that what it is in the
capacity doubles or triples that's a
cation that's what it is that's that
word how long a set did he do he did
about an hour 10 wow that's not that
long for him for him no no he did 10
minutes to the seller the other night I
had to follow him it was really 10
minutes he did his SNL thing how was it
great he did a mic I don't want to give
anything away but he does a mic drop and
it ends in the nword oh that's all my
shows then so I'm nice to see somebody
else doing it I was I was surprised to
see that Dave was hosting SNL this
weekend yeah you know cuz he usually he
hasn't been doing anything for years and
is does he have something though is he
promoting something no I just want to
hear his take I think and he was like
yeah I give it to you but you got to
realize this guy hasn't been on his show
ended in '
0605 to sell out Radio City 11
times and not be on TV in 10 years is
amazing it really is yeah he's uh he's
really grabbed the this the country by
the balls added to his Mystique the fact
that he walked away but he was M he
would have been massive either way there
is something though to leaving while
things are [__] really hot you know
what I mean yeah exactly it's like yeah
Seinfeld for the rest of his life I mean
it's been way longer than that since he
left TV and no matter where he goes he's
going to sell out what year did he quit
that show 98 9998 I think 98 or 99 yeah
and and he can he can literally play
wherever he wants he can do a theater he
can do an arena he can do anything but
he kind of hung in there with a little
bit of Comedians and Cars going gay and
then the other thing with the uh he's on
Letterman a lot or he was on Fon a lot
Chappelle's just gone he just disappear
he just yeah and it was almost like yeah
like there it was just rumors like oh he
popped up in a club last night and he
did n hours or whatever it was like
that's all he was doing yes so I'm
surprised that he's doing SNL though I'm
excited to see it I'm sure it'll be
really funny I'm sure it will yeah yeah
um what did him and Chris Rock do they
just sat there and chatted it was all
election chat oh cool yeah yeah two
Trump
guys yeah poor Dave Chappelle had to
come out and tell TMZ I'm not a trump
supporter cuz yeah cuz the quote went
everywhere about Hillary no he said his
quote was right by the way his quote was
right his quote was about permission and
sexual assault and he said did you just
dribble on yourself Jesus Christ came on
my own stomach embarrassing normally
that's on your
back his quote was Chappelle goes uh you
know Donald said that when you're famous
you can do that right they let if you
can do that if they let you that implies
content or consense consense sorry
consense they're probably content as
well but he said that's consent yeah so
it's not sexual assault and that's his
point and so he makes this point and
everybody goes crazy and goes like
Chappelle's a trump supporter obviously
and he had to go on TMZ and go no I
don't report Donald Trump I was making a
point about something that the guy said
yeah people are such and even if he did
who gave a [__] right I know they're
just looking for something to talk about
they love the story oh this whole Trump
thing am I right or wrong guys I'm glad
you brought that up like that
yeah yeah nothing's changed yet or he's
not in the the white house yet right no
it's got till the 20th he gets in right
away yeah have you seen uh uh Bill Bill
Clinton's black kid black kid oh yeah
yeah he has a black song has a black Sun
yes he does no well you could tell it's
legit because the black Sun insists that
it's true and he's trying to get to come
from Monica Lewinsky's dress to do a uh
DNA test yes I don't think she's going
to give the load up where do you think
she keeps that does she still have it I
thought it went was it went to one of
the like Smithsonian yeah something like
that is it in the Smithsonian I don't
know if it's on display I would assume
not [__] I think that they have it
though wow I think that it's it's looked
at as a piece of American history yes
presidential spoe yeah how much
presidential goo do you do you have
let's say
gooral Kenneth Stars investigators after
signing an immunity agreement why would
she need to be immune she didn't do
anything
wrong hold on let me see uh blood sample
was taken from Clinton on August 3rd
that's that has nothing to do why they
why did they what take his blood why
didn't he just admit it who bill yeah
maybe was hoping it wasn't his exactly
ah chick suck dick all over this white
house it's not mine hoping it was a
secret service load yeah so the kid the
kid reaches out and says please give us
the dress because we won we can't get a
DNA sample from Bill Clinton and the kid
I feel bad for the kid the kid's an
adult by now but I feel bad for him cuz
you can tell his mother has just all his
life been telling him that Bill Clinton
is his father what was the story he
[__] her in the bushes yeah oh I
forget what it was yeah he [__] her
behind a sh rub yeah I remember I think
it was in an alley or something a thing
in an alley I I think shrubs I think it
was shrubs right I think that the woman
was like a a prostitute and it was in
the shrubs in the projects is that right
yeah I think you're right yeah wow I
think so oh yeah he was there and he
pulled out his jogging pants yes she
said bill was on one of his notorious
jogs and stopped by the projects to [__]
a prostitute in the bushes she knew she
knew that that the kid's his because he
was her only white client
right and the kid's a light-skinned
black young man so does he look like
Bill no not no he looks like Larry
Fishburn in 1980 he does that's him did
you see he reached out to Obama now cuz
Monica Lewinsky will not give up the
dress I wouldn't either she won't give
up the DNA sample believe it or not and
this was startling to a lot of people
she's ignored the kid altogether she
won't talk to him she won't acknowledge
that Bill Clinton's black son needs some
of that crusty jism he doesn't really
want the dress because then it'll ruin
him this is all part of it right if he
gets the dress it'll all be over the
minute he gets proof that like this is
[__] it's done he might really
believe it though like you said his
mother probably told him that's your dad
oh he's been brainwashed and when you
want to believe it so bad you know he
wants to the last thing he wants to
think is it's just another dude that was
not there for him yeah some other guy
named Bill who kind of looked like
Clinton a little bit but not even at all
play the sex yeah this dude doesn't look
like Bill Clinton even slightly and they
were showing him putting up photos of a
young Bill Clinton next to him oh right
there I see it the nose is the same
right there oh no that is bookland yeah
that you're looking at the photo of Bill
yeah you see the black guy next to him
how there's no resemblance whatsoever is
there in the nose you're right Mark is
right the nose is identical yeah
identical yeah it is actually it's very
very close they're both nose shaped n
they're very close though like like you
see the positioning is between the eyes
and mouth yeah
but they's an on each side wait a minute
they both have teeth in this photo you
know what that that is a little bit more
uh startling the shape of the mouth yeah
you're no it's not no I'm not I the
shape of the mouth isn't the same it's
similar the top of the mouth they both
have a mouth shaped mouth teeth yeah
yeah the top of the mouth isn't even the
same the lips are different everything's
different him it doesn't at all that's
Conor McGregor
oh uh they say OJ is a Kardashian's
dadad we've been hearing that for a
while I saw that I see more resemblance
between Chloe and OJ than I do between
this dude and Bill Clinton yeah yeah I
like to [__] Chloe oh so big I'd like to
reach under and hold her big hiny and
just pump away and apologize yeah I'd
like to climb that tree she's so big is
a big girl she have you seen her in
person before no um yes I have actually
she
I me oh yeah I did uh Lena with her you
did me me her Chris and Bruce but this
is back when she was fat yeah it was and
Bruce was there was it was it was Bruce
holy Mo she looks amazing yeah she's
tightened up I interviewed her one did
you just pass gas did did you get
excited when you saw Chloe I did she's
so pretty my my heiny just shot
something out I interviewed her once
before she was in as good shape as she's
in now and she was still hot I've always
had a a Chloe card I've been a fan for a
long time when do you think black guys
like
her they're okay with her like it's they
probably take her leave it you know who
I think would like Chloe Kardashian Bill
Clinton's illegitimate son oh yeah no
doubt about a huge fan how tall is she
she's got to be
68 I think about there what is she about
oh she's 5'10 wow that's my height 510
but she wears heels yeah big heels yeah
so she's she's probably 6' one in heels
how's the face up close it's nice it's
good all right she looks I remember she
looks good it's not like like she wears
a lot of makeup yeah I could see her in
the morning being a little look at that
that's not a good picture chip there you
know go back to L see ch's chip
Kardashian [__] s is a piece of
garbage what we got millions of bucks or
something making jokes about Lamar odm
yeah [__] Lamar odm money then he
fell
asleep [__] yeah it's word play humor
word play
y tweet that picture of [__] Chloe
chipperson that's good oh she looks
really Dum oh another one oh no I wonder
if she would make any jokes about
brothel yeah why don't you like my big
fat [__] ass or something you piece
of garbage that's
just just so over the top and direct
[__] yeah you think so yeah what are you
paying for hookers or
something see the beauty of the
Kardashians is they they go every kind
of type like you got the the Kylie who's
skinny and hot you got her who's like
meaty and got Kim who's kind of with a
big fat rump yeah with huge cans right
yeah all the all the white guys that
used to be into whoever the other pretty
one was who oh my God she is gorgeous
who's the third sister with Kim and
Kendall Courtney Courtney Courtney all
the white guys that loved Court she's 5
feet tall though is she they yeah I I
would be [__] Brad
Williams they all love the young ones
now though of course yeah you don't like
short gals not five feet I'm fine with
that no I like him 53 or whatever
doesn't make you feel like a man when
you have five foot dwar of a woman yeah
no I don't want that I don't want a girl
like can pick up and Shake about oh I
like that I like a big noie
headlock there she is cute yeah oh
that's Kendall goodl looking gal she's
not as curvy as the rest so uh well
she's got the uh the Jenner blood m in
her not the Kardashian or OJ blood I'm
so confused the Kardashian Jenner yeah
yeah I don't know they're pretty popular
family it's actually a great point to
bring up really really solid really
solid can you see her [__] lip there or
no no it's a leotard no no
there I don't think so I don't know am I
wrong okay we'll zoom in on it for
Pete's sake let's stop guessing it's not
her [__] lip I'm looking she's not
posting her [__] lip on Instagram you
might not know the [__] you don't
think that they check their [__]
first of all that's not exactly a candid
shot no she takes a picture you don't
think that might be a little fat [__]
lip bulge I wish no all right but it
wasn't crazy of me to think it they
photoshopped their Instagram photos
they're not just like oh let me take a
quick snapshot and go up maybe she tried
to photoshop out her giant vag and a
[__] only a little bit got
photoshopped out there wasn't enough
Photoshop to take care of how big her
vag was oh she got [__] she's hot those
legs are so thin yeah part like a little
cult yeah yeah like [__] like Bambi
on the
ice I'd like to shoot her
Mom oh my goodness wow that's pretty
great yeah God damn it we got some good
ladies in this country huh sure
do our best resource is white women yeah
so I want to play for you uh this kid
asking Obama now for Bill Clinton's DNA
to help him out all right and I guess
Obama just has like I think when you're
president you just have the Vault with
all the EX president's DNA like a little
sample from each one you know you the
juice to pick up the phone and go Bill
why don't you help us out I don't
know you don't think he would help him
out no I don't hey Bill how about a
Seamon sample I don't think it's a good
idea Bo Bill Bill your son called he's
looking for for a seen sample to prove
that he's your son he's not my son
should had a little
beep can we have the little
beep the Boop yeah you have to add a
censorship beep in there because I could
see where that would come in handy yes
it oh so this is have to do with
something I would never [__]
a bill this is Barack Obama talking to
you you can't no I no you're one of the
good it's
offensive uh let's hear what Danny
Williams had to say to President Obama
on the Quest for for figuring out
whether or not Bill Clint is actually
his
father it's cool music right Obama my
name is Danny Williams he sounds just
like him I am the son of that's Bill if
I have ever heard anybody with Bill
Clinton's voice that is that's Bill
Clinton oh yeah you can hear it you can
hear the Little Rock in him mhm I'm
reaching out to you today because I know
you can understand me you also grew up
without a
father and and you are our first black
president you have supported black lives
matter and My Brother's Keeper so I know
that you believe my life
matters I have is he is he saying Barack
I need for you to reach out to Bill
Clinton to get his DNA for me yeah I'm
black you're black let's do this he's
saying I'm black you're black help me
get the [__] of that white
devil that's it that's it I'm surprised
he couldn't convince him of that yeah I
think those are Leonard Cohen
lyrics oh yeah Leonard Cohen died bummer
huh I saw I thought he was been dead for
years no you kidding that's not the
appropriate attitude yeah I had no idea
he was he was alive I thought of Sam
Morel he's a big Leonard Cohen fan yeah
we texted at like 2 in the morning yeah
I figured it out though I got him
confused with Lou Reed I thought Sam a
comedian I thought I never like Lou Reed
no he sucks stinks he doesn't see just
talks talks right call a girl goes aoop
aoop D doop shut up shut up but he's
doing it to the music I don't care well
how he's doing he [__] stinks he
sucks it's all it's all like a cool guy
thing yeah what's his one good song the
one that Ron Bennington would use the
satellite of Love or something there was
one he would do that was okay what about
perfect day I don't remember that one
perfect day is a good song I don't know
it I don't know that one either no maybe
we'll open the show with it tomorrow I
don't know it he's all attitude there's
no substance Lou Reed yeah I agree well
he's not attitude anymore EX
he's dead latitude leard Cen yeah yeah I
thought I thought Leonard Cohen I got I
got him confused and when they Ann like
when I saw it on Facebook last night
that Leonard Cohen was dead I was like
what is this one of those like
anniversary posts somebody saw it and
said oh two years ago you posted about
this guy dying like no no no that's news
of today yeah he's done he's dead of as
of yesterday I didn't care I just went
sweet you said that when you went out
Leonard Cohen dying yes I know you had
that that's a popular one oh nice people
love that one it's really real popular
all right let's go back to uh our friend
uh uh Danny Williams uh Bill Clinton Jr
years to contact my father Bill Clinton
and also my stepmother Hillary Clinton
to G love and acceptance and in the past
few weeks I have released a video about
my story and I requested that my father
submit a d a samp looks nothing like him
the video has been seen by over 30
million people holy [__]
I also went to the National Press Club
in
Washington where I appealed to miss
Monica
Lewinsky hoping that she would provide a
sample from her famous blue
dress you know the Panic that is going
to sink into his mother if anybody were
to say all right we'll submit a DNA
sample ah
right they said they wouldn't do it just
move on just move on the government
switched it the government switched it
exactly blue dress I thought it was gold
oh that whole thing do you off the
subject do you remember the blue and the
gold dress and it would different
answers out of different people which
one did you see you know it's funny I
saw we should probably get back to this
guy so we
blue or was it gold who cares who cares
the radio audience wants to know they
don't it's a topic from two years ago
you think that was captivating
moment did you think your pauses were
building anticipation they certainly
were that's how I'll deliver information
I'll be like you know this guy
said what did he say no no see you don't
yell that
builds people can't wait to hear my next
syllable oh and then do they get
frustrated when they realize it's a
colossal waste of time I don't think
they do realize that oh I see I see I
see now that's radio yeah how about uh
uh let's get back to it we were just
about to I know but I like to throw it
around throw it you have like little
ways we throw it to the video that make
this sing just play the [__] video de
B hold on I don't like that pause it
let's
uh throw to the video
nothing I am fing a fraternity lawsuit
oh no but it can take years and cost
more money than I can afford
ah President Obama I have to know who I
am I have to know that my father and my
stepmother will accept
me it's
embarrassing Hillary she has the power
to convince my father to provide a DNA
sample why would she do that I know you
are endorsing my stepmother for
president please ask her to step up to
prove that my life does matter good tie
in going back to the black thing me and
my kids have a place in her Village too
he's got kid he's using the village line
I thank
you he's using the [__] Village it
takes a village we have a place in her
Village yeah yeah it takes a village you
think he wants a little of that Clinton
money oh he wants to he wants to say you
know what I'm thinking cuz they we you
just bought the house next door to you
in chap
maybe me and my maybe me there's a great
song about
that do you know what would be great I
hope it's true I hope [__] Bill
Clinton dumped a load in
1976 yeah and now [__] they cut into
Chelsea's inheritance yeah Bill's just
sitting there going like this is [__]
ridiculous then again would he be
entitled to it if he's not an adult oh
yeah he might yeah yeah OB if he's an
adult if he's not underage yeah maybe he
would be unless wrote him out of the
will well his mother yeah you don't have
to give inheritance to your kids unless
they die and there's no will but
couldn't you sue for back child support
or something like that no I don't think
so uh could if somebody skirts and
doesn't admit to the kid or won't take
the DNA test or whatever if you find out
that you were avoiding it I bet you
could sue for back child support or
something like that yeah yeah yeah well
the mother enti there's actually audio
of when they met no yeah the mother was
in the bushes come and get
it she doesn't sound black I know that's
why he liked her it was late I couldn't
see that was that was enough to convince
Bill huh yeah I stuck it in her
Hooch that's him apologizing to Hillary
yeah I couldn't help it she made it look
like I was coming in her
mouth that's own sound clip just an
excuse for the sound clip didn't make
sense certainly no it didn't oh you
don't think this woman the mom's not bad
looking for what for one of the way outs
from the Flint St she [__] awful
looking she is terrible
looking she's terrible looking she
really is all
right dead hope or
think let me see her maybe it's the uh
it's the wig I don't like oh it's a wig
yeah she it does look a little like
James Brown you're right it's not a good
wig no it is light skinned though
compared to her just saying yeah I love
that he's he's very lightskinned which
means it could be any white person which
probably means it's bu he is
lightskinned it might be a president
yeah that's a good point yeah yeah could
be
Reagan uh and we I guess she said that
she brought this up years ago and nobody
listened to her you know how annoying it
is if you're Clinton and it's true and
this woman was just holding up your
picture on [__] social media godamn
internet you know no must have been Gore
with with the worldwide web shut up Al
they're all going to come out of the
woodwork Bill we invented this tool
where everybody's going to be able to
communicate with each other and
information is going to be passed around
triing under your hat Al they're all
going to come out of the woodwork you
don't understand people are going to get
their information and share it with the
world I don't need that
sh piece of
garbage
is Bill slipping into chip yes he is I
[__] her in the bushes and
chis boo oh man how relieved has Hillary
got to be huh well she's probably humil
I think she's humiliated you think so
humiliated come on humil it's a ter if
she would have lost to Mitt Romney or to
Ted Cruz she wouldn't have been she
would have been like I lost but she lost
to Donald Trump it's embarrassing it's
humiliating oh and the uh I I really
enjoy and again I'm such a [__]
pushover I really am but I liked the
meeting that they had in the White House
you they don't like each other him and
but no they don't Trump looked nervous
it's the first time I've ever seen him
look tentative it was almost like again
he he I didn't know they had never met
right so here's the sitting president
they' never met they' never met I didn't
know that and Trump said that we've
never met each other before uh do you
have the audio of trump it was it was
actually really good Obama
I think in that one looked much more
comfortable even though he's obviously
not happy about it Trump looked uh
slightly nervous I also I also think
that Trump didn't doesn't exactly know
how to handle this position you know
what I mean like he's so used to whether
it's in business or the last year and a
half of running this campaign being the
alpha male and just going up on stage
and talking [__] and being aggressive
and B now he's not fighting anybody
anymore he won and I don't think humil
interesting or taking a backseat to
anything comes natural to him I know but
I think this was was frightening for him
Mark are you upset about the about the
spilled drink on your shirt a little bit
yeah why cuz you're covering it you
can't even see it if you don't have
eyes it does it does I'll get over it
but it looks like well it looks like DED
[__] that looks like yeah Danny Williams
wants
it is that his name yes is he looked
uncomfortable man he looked cu the way
his hand was yes
he looked like and his posture was bad
he was he was slouched over the
magnitude of this moment like he's with
the sitting US president it's a it's a
big deal and and Obama look the bottom
let's say what you want about him he's
been in more uncomfortable situations
than Trump has ah yes and he's good at
this with the entire country watching
it's just the two of them you can't make
an [__] out of yourself you can't
embarrass yourself you've got the job I
I I kind of liked this you know and
again I'm a pushover so I just buy it I
liked it let's listen
to want to do everything we can to help
you succeed because if you succeed then
the country succeeds please well thank
you very much President Obama um this
was a meeting that was going to last for
maybe 10 or 15 minutes and uh we were
just going to get to know each other we
had never met each other pause for a
second Adrian it's not a flattering
chair for him also he looks a little
heavy in that chair he's he well his
face looks really fat and red and
there's a bust behind it so you can see
it's not just the his face really is fat
and and he's and he's slouched over and
and you can see his whole body and you
can see all the way cuz he got very big
in the gut and hip area over the course
of the campaign uh and I I I would make
a bold prediction after seeing this we
know that Donald likes to celebrate with
a little fast food yeah does he yeah I
believe I believe especially hanging out
with Chris Christie a lot he's going to
get much bigger as president and I'll
tell you I'll tell you something uh too
he met this president who he has been
[__] talking yes I've met I've met
people we've jocked toered and you're
always like a little like hey guys yeah
don't tell me in front of the whole
world when you've [__] talked this guy
for all of this time you were wrong
about the birther thing right and it's
it's now you're meeting him that's the
important thing that people I don't
think are all remembering it's not even
just over the course of the campaign
saying he's the worst president he spent
all that time years ago he been [__]
on him for years with the bther thing
like he spent months and he was wrong
demanding well he wasn't maybe he was
wrong but he definitely came out the
winner of that scenario cuz he forced a
sitting president to show his birth
certificate Obama finally had to say
look here's the [__] birth
certificate stop and Donald goes oh okay
all right well I guess I saw it then
yeah also that's a bust of MLK behind
him so he's really giving him the side
eye yeah but Trump is really like he he
has that thing like all right I talked a
lot of [__] then forward that's the way
you are when you meet someone who you
blasted totally like all right guys and
he went out of his way to say nice
things that's how Kevin Brennan is
around
me there are people wondering if uh he's
going to keep the MLK bust in the in the
white house or not yeah cuz it's a tough
move ah there's no way he's keeping that
but if he doesn't keep it and people and
he films anything in that room going to
be like use no he's going to take that
to the bowling alley
downstairs
and he'll probably go
bowling yeah no we cover that Mark kind
of covered that just like us yeah so all
watch more this great uh the meeting
lasted for almost an hour and a half and
it could have as far as I'm concerned it
could could have gone in for a lot
longer we really um we discussed a lot
of different situations some wonderful
and some
difficulties um I very much look forward
to dealing with the
president in the future including
Council uh he's uh he explained some of
the difficulties some of the it's funny
how like you could te how you could tell
he's nervous because certain words like
he said I have great respect like he
didn't say have great respect for him
it's like when you're when you're when
you're kind of there but you're not
there and like you're not thinking
clearly about everything you're you're
just trying not to [__] up right he
doesn't know how to portray himself as
an equal to the person in the room with
him all he knows antagonized yes
antagonize competitive com be better I
mean every business person that you've
ever been in a meeting with every CEO
has this Vibe of kind of one-upsmanship
they do he can't do that in that room
but his body
language is is not like I'm trying to
come off this way he looks like somebody
who is kind of he doesn't know how to
talk he he's a bit humbled by it or
Blown Away by it again it's it is
slightly intimidating when you're
sitting with a guy one-on-one who is not
intimidated by you who uh you who is you
know TR don't forget the only one-on-one
they've kind of had was in that White
House Correspondence Dinner where
[__] Obama wrecked him laid into him
yeah so the the thing is you're both
hoping the other one is just cous
[__] publicly yeah because
Obama beats him in the same room because
he's just because he did it at the at
the correspondence Diner like they were
in the same room and Obama got the
better of him but when they're separated
Trump's gotten the better of him every
time like the the bther thing Trump
absolutely got the better of him and
just winning this election Trump has
completely spoiled Obama's Legacy yeah
because destroyed it Obama lined up with
Hillary and and said I support her and
people want we didn't a lot of his
people went to Hillary and well not only
that but also went to Trump people are
going to look at this and be like how
did the Trump presidency happen he is it
wouldn't be I'm if if just a republican
were voted in that doesn't spoil Obama's
Legacy it's Trump no no no I'm not
saying about the Legacy I'm just saying
that people are so shocked he got
elected we just had eight years of a
very very leftwing Democrat so it's not
shocking that and it's also not shocking
[__] Celebrity Apprentice guy wins
meaning that there's a very there's a
more uh a right-wing uh election because
after a very very right-wing George Bush
you had uh one of the more liberal
presidents in history it just when when
one of the extremes goes then the other
one tends to get elected to balance it
out it just happens to be him and this
is looked at his balance no but I mean
again people didn't probably want to go
to a further left turn the country
doesn't seem to like to go in one
direction for too long that's true it's
like that that weird little course
correction yeah absolutely where it's
going forward and just kind of toggling
left or right I had to say toggling so
we but look at hair metal and then
grunge you got to go the other way right
got to compensate that's what the way it
is yeah Mark you've done a lot of radio
shows right sure have you ever been on
one where a person has to use a
soundboard with their own voice on it
yeah I you know I do a lot of road
comedy and they use their own voices on
their soundboard no this is pretty
highend it is good highend he just makes
me so happy oh I'm going to come like he
can just say that he doesn't need to
push a button for come on man if I want
my prick fold I'll do it myself that's
right Sam he couldn't have said that
wouldn't have said that but I'm happy
Mark's here this guy's a riot see that
tell a story tell a story oh [__] I can
just relax and enjoy chip with the rest
of you nobody enjo
it oh let's get back to the uh Trump
Obama meeting
yeah the highflying assets and some of
the some of the really great things that
have been achieved uh so Mr President it
was a great honor being with you and I
look forward to being with you many many
more times in the future thank
you that was as nice as it could have
been yeah watch this moment too beat red
questions thank you guys yeah he
looks A good rule don't answer questions
when they just start the last one that
was a little banter yeah but see this is
why I love that moment because uh uh
Obama like Taps Trump on the shoulder
and he goes good rule you know don't let
them ask questions when they're yelling
it when they're yelling it saying like
I'm the president I know and Trump had
to go like yeah it's always the last one
uhhuh and Obama's like no what no that's
not what we're talking about they uh
hope you look they could wind up getting
along
great because Obama's interest in Trump
is probably like now that Trump's got
the job yes he's Obama's a man he
doesn't want to be humiliated by a
sitting president like you don't want
the next president regardless to undo
everything you did and and degrade
everything you did and to [__] like
anything that has to be undone can be uh
can be undone with a certain language
that seems like you're just repairing or
fixing or or or or nudging it along as
opposed to going this is garbage take it
out you understand what I mean there be
an attitude about the changes too so
that he's saying if if he kind of makes
nice Trump will come in and not just
take a big [__] over everything he's
done so far look I try we're a day and a
half in um America is great again his
Twitter he really needs to stop
complaining about the protesters again
that you're the president he did
what did you see the second tweet what
first he complained about the protesters
yes but then later either early this
morning or late last night he tweeted
something to the effect of like isn't it
great how passionate people are like he
did a complete 180 into into president
Ville he has to because you know again I
said this to I I love people protest
that's what you do when you're not happy
just don't break [__] and don't [__]
turn cars over yeah but it's very
American to not like something and
protest it that's fine but has this
happened before in history probably not
but this is a definitely a weird no
president has ever said this [__] right
before winning like you know what I mean
no no one has made people have made a
lot of statements that other people
didn't like but you mean like the
protests yeah well the day after they
probably would have happened in 2000
with bush and Gore but it wasn't
declared H for like however long it was
it was like a month or two years I don't
think it took quite six years but for
like a month or two and so by the end of
that process I think everybody was so
exhausted yeah they were like [__] it
they're protesting in hopes of the
electric College voting Hillary on
December they won't they can't they
absolutely can't there have been people
who are trying to advocate for that and
I think there's a there's a petition out
there going for it it'll never happen
under no circumstances and it would be
completely Dam it would be way worse for
everything if they just ignored the
Electoral College yeah you know I mean
they ignored the that's what we're based
on like if if the Electoral if the
delegates just decided yeah wow that's a
lot of signatures there
735 oh needed needed so there's 2.2
million signatures on this thing yeah
pretty good that's a lot of people she's
probably out though now it's been too
late it's too long she's already like
I'm already used to not doing it I'm
good exactly she's home just wearing
[__] those tight stockings to make
her cankles go
away like you know when you're going to
the gym and you're like oh the Gym's
closed all right that's it you can't go
back to another gym it's the best
feeling when you get there and you hear
the door
like oh it's Veterans Day they're closed
I tried great you get in the car and you
see somebody going to open the gym and
you're like I guess was closed you know
what am I going to do I'm not going back
then you say something fun like hey
let's go out and eat a piece of
cake
yell uh but the fun thing is if you go
to Taco Bell and it's closed you'll go
to another Taco Bell absolutely but the
gym you're like hey I did my part right
right I tried I tried I did everything I
could y that's pretty cool though like
she looks happy she's on the on the
trail walk well some lady said that she
went uh hiking out there in she's back
in chapaqua Hillary Clinton just another
one of the great uh cities of
Westchester oh she asked for a h picture
and she's hiking and this woman says
that she saw Bill Clinton and Hillary
Clinton and the dog just walking in the
woods they were just walking the dog
Danny Williams that's good that's good
Secret Service so and where's Bill
taking the [__] picture he's [__]
a woman in the
bushes why why is Bill not in the
picture I don't want to there's a baby
in that picture it ain't
mine I don't know it's probably a fake
picture to tell you the truth no this
went viral Jing s yeah are you serious
yeah yeah it's probably set up there's
no way that she I think that it was
Photoshop no it's not Photoshop but it's
probably set up I mean there's no way
Hillary is walking around a day after
the election with no secret service or
anything I didn't even think about that
good call there FY I just said security
where's the security and nobody listened
to
me on a minute that point I thought it
was just one of your sound effects why
does Sam get the credit for that I
clearly said there was no security yeah
I think it was set up I did say that I
think it was I think it was a
setup sorry Jimmy he said there was no
security we noticed that you said it
Travis not listening to me try don't
waste your time with the headphones dude
there was no let's go to the death box
for comments I'm just I'm just
unraveling cuz I'm tuckered out did not
sleep well you didn't sleep well last
night no that [__] Photoshop is
hilarious Obama flipping off Donald
Trump dude that's a
Photoshop that's actually a good call
you call them all out Jim you're calling
them all out let's go to Tom in
Nashville Tom welcome to Jim Norton and
Sam Roberts Tommy salami Mark people
invested in the show it's fun I like
Tommy Boy Hey I just want to let you
know first of all love you guys love the
show um she's already called and
conceded the victory to him that pitch
be out she she's gone no that's not
legally binding I mean Al Gore can no no
no no it's not Al Gore and George Bush
listen
alore Al Gore and George B Bush both
took back concessions in 2000 oh I'm
wrong holy crap thank you the font of
knowledge exactly sir they conceded and
then they like oh no it's not true yeah
dude you're the mayor you're the mayor
of wrong City don't be so violent to our
listeners Jim that's really mean what
did I say that wasn't
mean so stupid Joe before I noticed that
these secret Ser there was no one there
with them Joe and Virginia somebody
please compliment me hey they they said
on NBC Nightly News last night that bill
was was taking the picture that's why he
wasn't in it ah I wonder that too does
she have a picture with how do you not
just do a take the ugly kid out and make
him take the picture yeah probably a
girl based on the pink hat but it could
be him or just hold out a selfie she's
got to have one with Bill she can't no
she was was distraught over this a lot
of women were distraught over the
election they thought they were going to
have the first female president and I'm
sure to her at this moment Hillary
Clinton probably means more than Bill
does do you think though that she's just
out there with Hillary is a hero to
women point but how is there no secret
service though I want to make that point
again it's a setup she lost yeah they
just home you're a loser we're not going
to protect you where's all the
people I got to drive myself to Quicky
Mart she made a ton of money on this
though she's got to be living the she's
doing just fine yeah she's a fat cat M
really good didn't change my life right
back to to the job site with a lunch box
is that right bring a lunch box
container of coffee yeah you run around
the woods with a dog I'll
work don't presidents get secret service
for Life yes nion paid for his own what
but presidents do get secret service for
Life yes they do that's true so then why
the [__] is Bill Clinton walking around
the woods with just a dog because again
there's times where they probably just
want some privacy in the woods I bet you
after this somebody got
fired yes some [__] with a baby walked
up to us we could have been killed
he's screaming yeah as soon as they walk
away he picks up his cell phone who is
this [__]
Searcher just an angry man yeah going
off the rails yeah where the [__] were
you tackle this
[__] uh she didn't sleep well last
night no I didn't well how come what
were you busy doing honestly I just went
to bed uh late normally I don't
um but I just was up last night reading
what time reading reading what time were
you reading
until 12 45 I was reading and somebody
said I'd love to come over and look at
that book with you oh a reading partner
I did oh nice did you just get a text
out of nowhere from somebody that was a
reading partner yep oh that's pretty
incredible good for you buddy that's not
too is this reading partner do they live
here or were they just in town they live
here and they were just like I'm in the
mood to read with you yeah let's see
what time the old texo came in and show
me a photo if you have it hold on let me
see the old textur when did the uh when
did the old ring ding go off to let you
know somebody wanted to read with you
let's see here yeah I picture your
little your little glasses falling off
when you got the text hold on now let me
see uh you think you think his his his
readers fell off his nose yeah oh my
word little sleeping cap I guess I'll be
reading out loud
tonight hold on second God damn it sorry
have some company uhhuh what are we
talking mine comp uh what are you
reading seems like you're going through
a lot of texts yeah yeah we talk a lot
are some of them uh
12:37 a.m. I respond 12:25 the text came
in 12:37 I responded so if a gal came by
you probably didn't get to sleep till
12:41
let's see what time the Uber left oh you
ubered her yeah oh 233 230 okay for a
couple hours for you an hour it's not my
nature to read for more than an hour no
just reading oh I see boy show biz huh
how great is that that's incredible has
that your world has to have changed
since you've been doing Arenas with she
she attracts a lot of women yeah AR full
of them odds are pretty good and they
can't [__] her so right right it's it's
going well oh that's got to be amazing
have any girls sucked your penis
yes and balls and balls too huh yeah
yeah yeah not a lot of reading no no
reading have you done any threes Sims
yet I have that's incredible it's uh
it's intimidating I got to tell you is
it yeah I've done a few it's just you
know you got to please two
[__] it's really uh eloquent the way
you put why is it intimidating cuz both
their [__] are bigger and darker
your had you not done that before this
kind of round of no not at all I've
never done one so your life so this
really has been a life changer oh yeah I
mean I'd done threesome but it was the
devil's threesome if you know what I
mean [__] yeah that's chip I don't think
that's what you mean two
guys so had you really done a devil's
3on before i' done a few with the with
the same guy you did we were buddies we
were close what's the devil's threesome
with another guy and a
child
so you had a you had a buddy that you
just double teamed girls with yeah like
that was your thing that wasn't our
thing it just kind of happened a lot how
many times did you do it with him three
I think that's a lot yeah we look the
same so the girl was like ah why not and
did you was it the same girl every time
no no no so you just go and pick up a
girl and be like me and my buddy do this
together he was kind of a selfish guy so
I'd be [__] a girl he would just come
in and be like I got the mouth really
and they were I mean we made with
it what a good guy you are was he was he
your roommate no no just a buddy we we'd
hang out a lot I could never have a
threesome with a friend like I've done
it at times I've had them with uh you
them with Ron Jeremy yeah yeah yeah I've
had them with uh boss I've had them with
you [__]
Bonnie no she [__]
me um no I've had them with a few
friends one who I can't name cuz he was
married
oh I had a threes with the same woman in
three of my buddies at different times
holy moly so that you would you supply
the woman and be like hey in this case I
would she liked Rees and so but it I
always have to be with another
guy yeah she just wanted to [__] a
couple of my friends cuz she like comedy
so she would blw me while Florentine
[__] her she and Voss is such a piece
of [__] she was blowing me while Voss
[__] her and then as soon as he came
he's like I'm G to go out and
smoke and he just leaves me and her
there he so tacky what was it like to be
left with Judy Gold
[Laughter]
oh man Voss was he wearing the Fedora
was it a this way back in awful haired
Voss this is this is [__] just Jerry
curl splashing all over the place 956 20
years ago the mullet swinging around
terrible bad
teeth so oh God look at that that's the
voice I know holy [__] so you like but
you were okay doing it with friends I
didn't like it but it was more fun to do
cuz they were my buddies you know what I
mean but I wouldn't I didn't because you
joke about it later
yeah we did yeah yeah my friend had a
huge hog that was a that was a bummer it
was a bummer for you yeah feelings of
inadequacy you don't want to especially
if if if if if he's got the mouth then
that's going to be your best visual on
his hog the whole time right true that's
good though you're watching her suck a
porn dick that's kind of cool it just
sucks it's your friend it's your friend
and then you know you know what I mean
right right you know you don't measure
up then you lean over to kiss her and
it's like ah I know and then you're
[__] then when he's [__] her she
seems enjoy it more ah it's it's a
bummer it does sound like a bummer yeah
oh my god I've never been filled this
way like the the [__] lips are being
like sucked in you like yeah yeah that's
a bummer yeah he's he's hitting spots
that you just couldn't ah you're killing
meim he in real estate that you just
couldn't
reach Dam it would you mind watching
that happen to a young
lady no it's required if I'm
D and you have to tell me about it while
it's happening the stallion's on his way
over you just can't feel me like
[Music]
this that's all you need but it was just
one reading partner for you yeah last
night mhm you had a good time
yeah it sounds like you did yeah yeah
little reading was good so the thre Sims
that you've had Mark not the devil's
threes Sims but the newer ones yeah have
you had to like work those or did they
just kind of happen uh I kind of had to
work them you did see that's good
because I feel like if you're in a
position where it's just getting thrown
at you uh then your sensitivity can go
down and should that dry up yeah you
don't know how to go back out there cuz
that muscle isn't hasn't been hasn't
been worked you know what I mean I see
like you haven't had to put the work in
so you don't remember yeah and you
appreciate it more you're like I earned
this yes I put some more I earned that
somebody's taking away your threesome
yeah you go to [__] two girls one guy
jumps on the [__] and it squishes out
you're like I earned that come on man
yeah you point at your dick treat
yourself but I did a thre with one girl
and uh after it was all said and done
one of them fell asleep and I remember
just banging the other one and being
like oh this is kind of nice right like
the pressure's off a little bit but the
thre was great I'm appreciative I'm
grateful but once she fell asleep I was
like I'm just going to go to town on
this skank cuz that I know I can do yeah
I have confidence there right how many
threesoms have you done with two girls
uh five okay so by the time you get the
fifth one though got pretty good Rhythm
I'm all right now but everyone's
different you got to learn two women at
once it's a whole thing they suck your
dick together you hope one of them
doesn't have plaque breath I don't mind
that how awful would that be if they
blow two girls are blowing you and the
one with the sloppy his head has tartter
breath oh God tartter breath you know
that awful [__] flu breath I had a
girl blow me once with flu breath how
was it horrendous wait how do you know
she SM it while she's sucking your dick
wow that's pretty low down cuz the
saliva is coming out yeah it's like it's
literally like she [__] took a
garbage truck and she's tipping it on
its side over my [__] wow nice [__]
nice breath bad breath girl dry and
flemy that's exactly it horrible radio
team smells
like dry and FL in the a yeah dry and FL
is disgusting that [__] it smells
like sinuses bad breath girl is just
going down on you when it's time for the
other girl to suck your dick she just
leans in and goes oof she just has to
back away oh for Pete sake it's like
when you're chewing on a pen you sniff
the pen you're like saliva is horrible
you have to be like that's not my dick
that's her that's the girl who came
before she's like no that's his dick I
don't know it's not me his precom smells
awful like tooth
decay dead tooth smell is there anything
worse than when someone has a [__]
gray dead tooth and it reeks you want to
just grab them by the ears and scream
fix that then put your knee in their
face knock it out for yourself [__]
awful that dry flemy breath oh it's the
[__] worst that's rough you've had
you've had a scenario where you've had a
woman with a dead
tooth yes ah yes I mean all the
[__] we have a dead soul with a
dead tooth it's just get it done go to
the [__] dentist yeah yeah God
Almighty I've known you for four years
and it's still gray hey Battleship tooth
how does that happen is it could be the
filling no no it's the inside out it
just goes away it's just done it's just
a rotting tooth yeah oh that's rough and
yeah it's like the front tooth so it's
not like you can't get a filling in your
front tooth no you got to just fake yeah
pull it out bad smell yank it out even
with gum it stinks it doesn't do any
good no it doesn't how about this to
everyone listening check your [__]
mouth yeah we all have it once in a
while but I get my teeth clean if a few
times a year right go get your [__]
teeth cleaned and if people are [__] if
people are complaining about it well
it's a tea is not a good morning
beverage ah yes why cuz it dries out
your mouth oh yeah yeah yeah gives you
terrible dry bad breath mouth it does
tea in the morning tea isad ice tea is
very bad do you know anyone that drinks
iced tea in the morning I've encountered
does make their breath smell awful awful
really oh very bad [__] old southern
men I do declare yeah
he's sipping a mint julip as he puts his
balls in Sam's
mouth yeah terrible